nell'episodio precedente no no mi sono
chiuso con un [ __ ] mi sono chiuso
con un cagliari 2 accettato scheda sì ma
stai scherzando ragazzi non fa ancora
vento di ragioni
lo schiacciatore tutela a tutti ragazzi
e benvenute questo nuovo video sono fa
vj ed oggi andiamo avanti con penombra
black flag che eravamo rimasti
praticamente sono entrati in questa in
questa specie di stanza dove dovrebbe
dove doveva esserci una gnocca perché mi
hanno detto così
ma non c'è la stagnola c'era sto tizio
brutto vogliamo uscire questo è un
pettine
che bello da mina lametta che in italia
anche il bene ma c'è un computer mi
sembrava strano io voglio soltanto
controllare facebook e poi ragazzi
controllo blocco porte camera di sblocco
sbloccato sbloccato qualcosa la camera
di equilibrio chimica che cazzo è non lo
so neanch'io password questa la sua
questa me la ricordo pif gay
ok ci dovremmo ci dovremmo noi incorre
spesso perfetto banana 17 a caso non lo
sa per ragazzi non importa l'importante
è che ho sbloccato qualcosa anche sono
capito cosa per la passa dobbiamo
ricordarci perché poi ci devo tornare di
sicuro perché ho sbloccato qualcosa non
mi ricordo neanche più dove cazzo devo
andare perfetto eccoli sai che saresti
primi disperatamente solo senza di neve
roma clicca sotto ha chiesto niente ma
fatti i cazzi tuoi se riuscissi a
trovare la strada per andare allora 4
che è perfetto
ci siamo ragazzi mi avete anche se
pagato ragazzi sta andando avanti lo so
io non so cliccando niente fermi anche
sarà bloccato di brutto con kakà
dobbiamo trovare ecco infatti lo sapete
io me lo ricordavo questo l'avevo fatto
ma poi erano cancellati salvataggi
comunque c'è una a una
c'è del sangue
e già questo non va bene ma non importa
andiamo avanti ii qui c'è una dove cazzo
siamo finiti
ragazzi se vi siano una ventola del
computer quando ho una avendo su ebay
nel dubbio comunque è una va bene
trovato della droga semi scopre la pula
son cazzi ragazzi voi non avete visto
niente e non me la sono neanche tanto
intascata mi dico non c'è cos'è vita a
loro e mi trascino è ok ok devo fare ho
capito cosa sono i cosmica volta ecco
l'antidoto devo trovare devo mettere
tutti gli ingredienti prima che li trovo
tutti ci vorranno dei secoli ma non
importa
ragazzi non mi ricordo neanche più dove
un altro ok greco siamo tra porca
[ __ ] se si aprisse sarebbe tutto più
un altro ragazzi mica sono un fenomeno
lo so trovare allora sono tutti qua
dentro per forza mi sto trovando a
manetta e la ragazza ce la posso fare
sono arrivato a 4 incredibile allora
sono mi me ne mancano due nel documento
che avevo trovato c'era scritto sei
buongiorno che bella cosa che chiazza è
morto brega
aspettate io ci ho paura aiona se ho una
sedia 76 sono ti muovi the line filo nel
no ragazzi ho troppa ho paura che si
sveglia la rai o una sedia sono tanzania
muovere un muscolo in qatar iva in testa
non si muove non si aspettate devo
assicurarmi le prima poiché i ragazzi
siamo che che figo sexy ce n'è un altro
club romo me ne mancherebbero altri due
o tre banche qua ce n'è un altro
perfetto
io presi tutti o sentirsi sentita la
musichetta spero di sì c'è una dice
miscela non completate impossibile
iniettare il campione c'è sì che in
attesa di inserimento sostanza presenza
crescente di composti andremo a mettere
a ok
devo mettere le cose no non le devo
metterli dove devo metterle ste cose
sembra un tubo di a reazioni come a ok
se non avete le materiali nella macchina
perfetta ci sono un deficiente rosario
riuscire a mettere sti cosi over senza
la sostanza chimica nella macchina che
dove li metto tutti a caso magari poi
creò la coca cola senza saperlo
la che ci dovremmo non lo so dice tutti
composti presenti analisi completata con
successo vai così miscela non complete
allora sei stronzo in attesa di
inserimento nella messa la sostanza
[ __ ] è una ma ben allora sei
bastardo fino all'ultimo io ti lascio
che la mia bellissima amica sedia se
volete raccontarmi le cose più belle ci
siete
torno presto allora se riuscissi si è
l'unica sarebbe laboratorio chimico ma
non riesco per chiedere essere
tremendamente difficile sto cazzo di
gioco allora punto dove la maschera
antigas
ho perso la maschera anno europeo che ce
l'avevo sul 1 io l'ho aperta sostanza ma
non si apre lo stesso è sbloccato questa
portata al computer ma non si apre tutto
il gas deve aver attivato il blocco e
allora siete bastardi forte da come si
[ __ ] se no si un cazzo o
peggiorato la situazione credo forse da
ecco infatti lo saperlo sono norme e
pensioni per ragazzi non so non farò mai
l'idraulico questo e sicuro per mario
era più bravo di me ste cose giochiamo
floppy bird usa che ci siamo mai così no
sentite io non lo farò e questo è anche
chiusa questa quindi non si capisce un c
io sono un [ __ ] ma forte c'era un
corso a terra grosso come non sono fatto
a non vederlo prima non è possibile
sì sì
grazie a dio anni per fare sto pezzo non
ci posso credere ho perso la mia
adolescenza su sto punto e incredibile
gira a destra ma [ __ ] io giro a
sinistra che cazzo vuoi così la destra
agirà destro a giro su giro adesso idea
geniale idea geniale presto c'è un
interruttore là dietro fa attenzione
[ __ ] non ho visto l'interruttore
lega dov'è e qui rega rega non ho visto
l'interruttore dove ok ok ok allora
facciamo finta di niente io io devo
attivare un interruttore che non vi è
questo e questo dove cazzo andato perche
non lo so dirà lincoln e si danno è
questo ma sono un deficiente ragazzi
oggi non ci sto punto mi ha attirato
lasciata nel culo ma sono ancora vivo
per miracolo cazzo mai si chiude
l'affare attraverso alla porta questa
zona verrà bloccata saranno che sono qui
di sicuro la nazione la telecamera mia
vice un momento in cui posso stare
tranquilli in questo caso di gioco conti
cazzo di cos'è sto schifo drogati
dovrebbe essere sto qui il figlio di p
io sono un medico esperto farò di te il
più bel bambino del mondo facciamo sta
cosa amico mio io
parimenti e distraggo le telecamere e
facciamo attenzione c'è qualcosa che non
va se c'è che non va ceppi junior casale
cazzo fif prendi tuo figlio prendi tuo
figlio
aiuto aiuto si dio santo
ok ragazzi ho visto la morte in faccia
[ __ ] tuel autobella altoparlante
che già non è il momento proprio è stata
una delle cose più assurde che abbia mai
fatto
devo condividerlo su facebook ho fatto
una cosa che nella mia vita non credo
riuscirò a c'è un punto di salvataggio
grazie a dio
almeno questo perché mi è stato
impossibile arrivare fin qua c'è una
valvola è bloccata bloccata secondo le
istruzioni in quest'azione al fosso di
fluidi stabilizzanti nella camera meglio
lasciar perdere
io non ho idea di che cazzo sia fosse
cosi che hai appena descritto ma non
importa
cos'è sto coso
ho capito minchia questo è un fenomeno
nelle sale giochi lo so fare da piccolo
sono riuscito a prendere un pupazzo
prendi penso sia la stessa identica cosa
ragazzi se riesco a prendere sto cosa mi
mi fate papa perché è impossibile
c'è una cosa fermi fermi vai se l'ho
preso per chiamo solo che non caschi
prima di arrivare alla fine e poi ho
vinto e vai ce la posso fare
sì ho vinto il coperchio è chiusa manca
qualcosa ma affanculo messo anche a
gettone non è possibile ho vinto brutti
bastardi gap per una volta che vinco
fatemi vincere maledizione è una specie
di equipaggiamento di sicurezza con quei
contenuti
ma devo mettere un perfetto mi sembrava
troppo facile promettere un container
che giustamente non ho io direi di fare
il bagnetto applichi junior prima di
andare avanti perché sennò non funziona
dalle api l'acqua non c'è l'acqua calda
araba il cross è bravissima e 6 sporca
furia di giocare a calcio fuori e di
sporchi ma è normale sei tranquillo e
devo capire cos'è questo recipienti
oddio se lo trova fini che non ci posso
credere
l'ho trovato subito danni per fare sto
pezzo ecco la sostanza meglio trovare un
nuovo modo per andarmene da qui non
posso tornare la strada in cui sono
venuto al collo l'avevo intuito che
adesso sto sfondando ragazzi dove adesso
posso dire alla levano ok ragazzi la
leva chavira stronzo tira prima che si
apra la porta si gira di qui minchia
impossibile e adesso che cazzo succede
si può stare tranquilli
un cazzo di minuto cosa è successo
perché se stavolta ragazzi non mi piace
sta musica non mi piace sta non so che
cazzo sta succedendo ma non mi piace la
musica è la madonna spiegate
[Musica]
si no come cazzo si passa io torno e
cazzo faccio farcela al passaggio di
soldi
togliti stronzo si si io santissimo
usciamo di qui maledizione via forse è
possibile avere tutta questa ansia per
per un videogioco non è possibile
c'è una cosa dove sin dove siamo so cosa
si pensa 6 pensando a modo per gli studi
rai
i [ __ ] pif [ __ ] hai rotto i
[ __ ] cosa sta succedendo perché che
cazzo succede ragazzi non vedo più
niente sta martellando probabilmente non
lo so se lo sapeva lui era lui era il
bastardo di merda che mi start e
l'andamento non vedo una sega perché non
vedo una sega che non si sposta perché
non si spostano le porte combinato me lo
spiegate melo su qualcuno mi spiace
perché è sparita una porta pesantissimo
ragazzi chiamiamo chiariamoci un attimo
perché non è possibile vogliamo tutto
che cazzo stone è tutto chiuso e tutto
fottutamente chiuso non posso andare da
nessuna parte non è normale
aprite io tantissimo perché non si può
avere un attimo in pace i sto gioco
l'altro ragazzi ci siamo adesso devo
mettere sta roba qui qua dentro
credo che tiferà se gli hanno fatto
conoscenza allora ragazzi ho perso tutte
le altre volte perché mi sono scomparse
davanti senza un apparente motivo
non chiedetemi perché o devo mettere la
sostanza questa qui da qualche parte qua
dentro
non la devo mettere dove cazzo lo devo
ammettere in sostanza va bene ho capito
il problema è che non funziona non so
che a circoli ma di melo macchia il
cazzo ne so io c'è scritto presenza di
composti e sostanze inserire sequenza di
missione del composto
philippe lasciami vivere non avrei
fegato vai avanti se un tale codardo
corpo con quattro arditi 6 a malapena
evoluto non ce la puoi fare
ma stai zitto e [ __ ] ce la posso
fare io faccio quello che voglio non
rompermi i [ __ ] era ad evocare i
composti devo cliccare la sequenza di
composti ho capito ma come cazzo faccio
a saperlo non me la ricordo nota che a
casa
l'azione portata inferiore al numero
invertito quindi pulsante di avvio più a
destra diventa di quattro casa si che
culo che essa questa e professionalità
stare già messo proprio due minuti giuro
allora avremo questo ce lo fa anni per
fare sta cazzo di cosa non ci posso
credere ciò ok
peccato succede che qualcuno aiutato
ragazzi che cazzo è successo ci ho messo
secoli per fare sta roba da dammi un po
di patata almeno come finalmente
finalmente finalmente cosa quindi cosa
finalmente pif può fare un calendario
quello lo sapevo anch'io cosa cosa cosa
matraia ok sono mi vostro nino
tranquilli c'è il tutto treno sapevo lo
sapevo non mi sono spaventato per niente
forse chi perché si è sfondato una porta
che cazzo succede che bel corpo miu miu
miu
no kat va bene ragazzi dire che posso
concludere qui l'episodio è vi annuncio
che il prossimo episodio di penombra
sarà l'ultimo della della serie perché è
praticamente l'ho finito il giorno
ragazzi che è un finale che non vi
aspettereste mai è stranissimo ma non
rispondevo niente vedrete nei prossimi
episodi ha comunque ragazzi io direi che
posso concludere qui come al solito
servizio è piaciuto lasciato un commento
mi piace anche la pagina di facebook
come non invitato la transizione se
l'essere presidi iscrivetevi noi ci
rimettiamo alla prossima pinto belle
ragazze
[Musica]